Adam once he always buys me dinner you
know I'll just call the studio and I
said you guys got to pay for these guys
or I was out at dinner at some fancy
restaurant and then they go Mr Sandler's
here and I go oh
but then he's got this whole back room
with 15 people and they're having some
big birthday party or something so I go
in there and I do a few thirsty bits to
get attention and then when I leave I go
hey put this on you know my Discover
card or whatever sir his whole thing I
go yeah so he goes sure so the next day
Identity Guard calls me
and says someone stole your card I go
they did there were some nine thousand
dollar dinner last night I go oh my God
I go that was me they're like it
couldn't have been you're not that
generous like oh no oh I was